(theme music)
- Wait. Stay standing.
Wait, take your shoes off.
- Wait, Frida. I'm
gonna take my shoes off.
- Wait, okay this is me...
- It's "Bring your daughter to work" day.
- This is like, wait... (crowd cheers)
I'm like,
literally, you've got
two really short people
and a tall people.
- Speaking of Sweden. I mean...
- I know. It's beautiful.
You are gorgeous.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me.
I'm such a huge fan.
- [Kelly] I am such a huge fan.
I don't know if they told you this,
I literally was obsessed.
I asked to have you on the show.
I love Vikings: Valhalla.
I think it's such a great show.
- [Frida] Thank you so much.
I am obsessed with it too.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Have you seen it?
Have y'all met?
Have you ever interviewed?
I didn't know if you met.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'm such a fan. I'm with Kelly too.
The stuff you do on that
show, and these legs for days,
when she gets out there, is incredible.
(crowd cheers)
- [Kelly] And your nails.
Great nail game. Everything's happening.
But I have to say that
with this show, I'm like,
I loved it. I saw the whole first season.
I'm like, "Do you ever get hurt?"
There's like big stunts y'all are doing.
- Yeah. I mean, it's a
very action heavy show,
and even though I was very
athletic growing up...
- You look like a superhero. So, yeah.
- I mean, I was so fortunate
that I got to do all of my own stunts,
but with that, you know,
sometimes comes injury.
I've got a couple of scars in my hands.
But there was one time,
we were about to shoot,
where we're doing the last rehearsal,
I have this big take down.
It's a six foot seven, big man.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I'm strangling him with my bracelet,
and we're doing this
big wrestle take down.
And of course I slip and
he lands on my elbow.
I get a fracture and I
have to go to the hospital
wearing my full costume...
(laughing)
And it's the middle of the pandemic,
so no one from production
could come with me.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- So I just show up at the hospital...
- [Kelly] Looking like a viking.
- Looking like a Viking.
Covered in blood, in my full armor.
And the people at hospital
are like, "What is going on?"
- Oh! And no one could come
with you, because of Covid.
- No! Because of Covid.
They just dropped me
off, and they're like,
"We're gonna come and pick you up."
So, I just walk into the
emergency room and they're like,
"What happened to her?"
- Haven't seen this before.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
That's hysterical.
- That was insane.
- So wait, so you...
Can you explain for everybody,
that hasn't seen Vikings: Valhalla,
like, what's your character?
Who's your character, and
what, who do you play?
So, I play Freydis Eriksdotter,
who is one of the most
infamously blood thirsty woman
of the Viking era.
She is the sister of Leif Eriksson,
that I'm sure people know
a little bit more about.
And yeah, so we are a continuation
of the original show Vikings,
and we're set 150 years after.
And it chronicles the most
famous Vikings that ever lived.
- So y'all, do you really,
do y'all study that?
Like, in like. in Sweden,
whenever you're a kid, you study?
- [Frida] Yeah. Yeah.
- That's really cool.
- I mean, being like Swedish, you know,
Vikings are such a huge
part of our culture.
- Yeah.
- [Frida] And so I was
really proud that I got to,
you know, represent my heritage.
And also, funnily enough,
my dad's name is Leif,
like my brother in the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my nickname,
growing up, was Freydis.
So...
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh!
- It's all like, too...
Yeah, and like, meant to be.
- [Kelly] It's a lot of happenstance.
- [Kelly And Frida] Yeah.
- Wow. That's crazy cool.
Your dad must think this
is the coolest thing ever.
So we've been talking
about doing things though,
for ourselves this year, in the new year.
What are you...
Instead of like a New Year's resolution,
which is, what are you
gonna do for you this year?
- Oh my God, that's such a good question.
I recently got married.
- Congratulations!
(crowd cheers)
I didn't actually know
that. Congratulations.
- [Frida] Thank you so much.
- That's so beautiful.
- Yeah. And I've been
in Ireland three years,
filming three seasons
of Vikings: Valhalla.
So, I'm gonna spend some
more time with my family.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's hard to
do when you love working
and you're, you know, you love
your jobs that you're doing.
It is hard to navigate that we're...
There is no such thing as balance, but...
- [Kit] No such thing as balance.
We'll go ahead and be your
wise older teachers over here.
(laughing)
- I love that.
- I love it though.
I love that y'all shoot in Ireland too.
I love Ireland.
So beautiful.
- It's so beautiful.
And the people, and the music.
- [Kelly] Mm hm.
- It was so unfortunate,
'cause we filmed during the pandemic,
so we weren't able to
experience going, you know,
to the pub and listening to...
- Oh, my God the pubs.
You've never met a stranger.
Everyone's so nice.
- And you're never alone.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is a good thing, you know,
you're always gonna find a friend.
But finally in the, towards the
end of filming season three,
that we just wrapped
a couple of weeks ago,
we were able to go out and,
you know, experience Ireland,
which was so wonderful.
- [Kelly] Oh, it's beautiful.